hey everybody movie retrospective time
doing some m night chamberlain
twist ending action that's what you're
talking about today yeah this guy here
man
[Laughter]
you know the deal he
you don't know what to expect with a
dude because he
he's kind of extreme you're either gonna
like his [ __ ] or you're not
and uh like i really loved his superhero
movies i liked us a couple of his horror
movies
and i liked this one it was pretty good
it was
i liked it i thought it was better than
signs
honestly yeah i mean and i know that
maybe that's i don't is that an
unpopular opinion because i kind of feel
like signs is pretty well regarded maybe
more than this one
but
honestly i think this movie is more
enjoyable to watch than science i don't
know why it's like i guess because i'm
not like a big alien uh you know movies
about aliens i'm not really perfect just
got some weaknesses i mean oh yeah like
all of his movies do some of some of the
dialogue's too lengthy a bunch of stuff
that you don't really need it's more
like in certain spots it's more like a
stage play than it is a movie you know
what i mean it's telling and not showing
but it then it starts it does do some
cool [ __ ] and it reminded me a lot of
of mid summer in some ways it felt like
a mid-summer like about a cult
that's what it felt like
yeah i guess a little bit yeah i kind of
feel like maybe uh the robert eggers
movie the witch it kind of has a similar
vibe to this
even though that was more straight up a
horror movie uh but yeah so we're
talking about the village which uh you
had never seen this and
somehow even though it came out in 2004
you did not know what the twist was
so i actually saw this in the theater
back in 2004
and i remember thinking it was like okay
i didn't love it but i thought it was
like pretty good but then in subsequent
years i didn't see it and then like i
kept sort of hearing a lot of people
[ __ ] on it and then i was like yeah
maybe it did kind of suck and like i
remember it being okay like i said i
didn't think it was great but i thought
it was like pretty good
um but i was like interested to watch it
again
knowing what the twist was
uh to see if it sort of like
recontextualizes it which it kind of
does i have to say got sigourney weaver
in it got the dude from predators what's
that guy's name adrian burton adrian
yeah see she knows he's got that adrian
dude in it it's got
um
who else is in this thing it's even
joaquin phoenix
phoenix is in it scott william hurt is
that it got the dude from um
uh from uh the kung fu movie that i like
i totally forgot that jesse eisenberg
has a very very small part in this some
people don't like eisenberg i think
eisenberg's a [ __ ] genius the two
that uh vivarium and art of self-defense
i think they're masterpieces just love
them
but i totally forgot well i guess in
2004 like jesse eisenberg wasn't like
super super on the radar like because i
can't i know that he'd been on the
social network but i think that came out
after that so but it was funny to see
him because i'm like hey that's jesse
eisenberg he's a bit part but he's in it
yeah he has he barely has any lines
there's a lot of just like a guy in the
village there's a lot of people you
recognize and you probably don't know
their names but yeah so i kind of feel
like i mean obviously i feel like even
people that haven't seen this movie
probably know what the what the twist is
so i know there's daughter in it too
yeah she's kind of starting but yeah
this is her first movie actually yeah
she's good in it she's actually really
good at it i think she's kind of one of
the best things about it
but uh yeah so like i said it was
interesting watching it again knowing
what the twist was like i said we're
gonna spoil it so if you somehow avoided
like tom somehow did avoid knowing what
the twist was
the thing about this that i think i kind
of
was more into this time
is that
the problem i think with the twist is
that
if you think about it in real life terms
it's not super plausible no i mean the
way that it's and there's like a lot of
plot holes and stuff but
i kind of feel like maybe maybe this is
just an excuse i don't know and i kind
of feel like this is maybe something
that m knight says a lot about his own
stuff
i kind of feel like you have to go into
this movie
and approach it like an allegory or like
a fairy tale
rather than
getting all like logically because
there's a lot of really really big plot
holes in this and like i said if you
think about
the way that the twist like everything
that would have to happen
for that twist to
be
should be plausible um i just don't see
i'm not saying it's impossible i'm just
saying that it's really really
implausible you know it might be it
might have seemed possible at the time
that he thought this up
as long as you didn't think about it too
much there are certain places in the
united states where you don't have that
many planes flying over but planes are
going to fly over this [ __ ]
it doesn't matter where you are
true and doesn't matter how big the
wildlife reserve
all right
it's taking place in basically like a
cult that lives in a real enclosed
encampment and it's like the 1800s it's
supposed to be 1897.
it says on the gravestone and all the
everybody pretty much there except some
of the some of the elders and the kids
think that it is 1897. it isn't though
it's modern time
and it's a cult that's
trying to withdraw from the [ __ ]
crime and
and and the uh
kind of like the tragedies of modern
life they were all victims of some kind
of crime yeah that's where they all met
each other like in a victim survivor
group and then they all got together and
said hey let's you know william hurt's
character he's like the elder and the
implication being i don't know if they
super super go into this but he's kind
of like i guess his grandfather had a
[ __ ] ton of money yeah and had this
piece of land that was big enough and
kind of remote enough that they could
kind of close it off yeah so they build
this 1800s town and they only bring in
1800 stuff and they had kids there the
kids don't know that it's
they don't know they don't they don't
know that it's not the 1800s
and on the outside of it
they have a whole security company
with a cover story that's that's trying
to protect it a what they think it's a
wildlife preserve but that's not what it
is it's cult
um
and they don't know they don't know what
what's in there which is not that
plausible
um a lot of stuff isn't plausible about
it in the long term now if if the elders
were taking a more of a
active role in dealing with the security
people in the outside world i would then
believe it
but they seemed to be like they
sequestered in there too like they
weren't going out
you know what i mean like they could
have easily gone out and gotten supplies
like medical supplies and come back to
me
that to me is kind of like the biggest
plot hole because
well that's what i'm saying about how i
think that you need to approach this
movie because like i said there's a lot
of really cool [ __ ] about this movie and
honestly i think that
it got kind of like mixed reviews at the
time like it made a lot of money it's
aged like it was successful um but i
think a lot of the criticism of it at
the time was like well there's all these
big plot holes like the biggest plot
hole um being well why send the blind
girl ivy out into the modern world to
get medicine when one of the elders
could just sneak out yeah and go and
like that one wouldn't know and because
it seems like the only the only reason
that was like preventing them from doing
that was like all the elders we made a
pact that we were never going to leave
and i'm like yeah but if your kid's
gonna die
well at the very beginning one of the
elders this kid does die and the
implication being that if they'd had
modern medicine the kid would still be
alive
so and it's also implied i don't think
they say this outright but it's also
implied that ivy's blindness could have
also possibly been prevented by modern
medicine as could noah adrian brody's
character as could his
mental impairment yeah
so um so there the thing about it though
like i said that makes me
wanna say that it's more like an
allegory or something like that is that
basically what this movie is saying is
that is it worth it like just because
you can't escape
sorrow you can't escape bad [ __ ]
happening to you in the world and it's
like
them actually they had all this like
crime and [ __ ] like that happened to
them like all their you know each one of
the elders had one of their relatives
like in the real world in philadelphia
i'm presuming because that's where all
his uh stories are set
this like we're victims of crimes and
we're killed and so they just said [ __ ]
this world we're just gonna go in this
place and we're gonna act like it's you
know little house in the prairie times
and uh you know and everything will be
fine and every and all of our children
will be safe
but that's not how [ __ ] works out
because obviously like i said their kids
died of preventable [ __ ] and then noah
ends up like committing a crime out of
jealousy
which you know is something that like i
said it's they thought they were going
to avoid so i think kind of the whole
point of the movie and we haven't even
got into the fact that the elders are
straight up lying to their children
saying well you can't ever leave because
there's monsters in the woods yeah which
was another twist the monsters were not
real they dressed up like monsters
though yeah i mean actually the costumes
were pretty cool i gotta say but so
these kids have grown up with an
illusion their entire lives yeah they're
trying to protect them and [ __ ] and yeah
and i'm gonna protect innocence that's
what they're doing yeah and like i get
that like i get and a lot of parents
have that um but
i think the whole point of the story was
that you can't really do that you know
what i'm saying not long term not long
term
even though at the end of the movie
it is implied that they intend to stay
there and continue the lie
because ivy goes out and gets the
medicine but she's blind she can't see
she didn't see the road she didn't see
the car
she just heard the dude's voice
and he gave her the medicine and she
went back to the village
not really being any the wiser
and she also didn't know that the
quote-unquote monster that she killed in
the woods was noah in a costume yeah
even though she did know that the
monsters weren't real but then
see that's another thing that i kind of
feel like and some people have pointed
out even people that are um
that are defending the movie they said
what m night should have done maybe
was made it so that because they said
it's really weird how
the scene where ivy is being stalked by
noah who she doesn't know is noah in the
monster costume in the woods
that it's like that would have been more
impactful for the audience
had we not already been informed that
the monsters were not real yeah and the
thing about it too was that she knew
that the monsters weren't real but
then william hurt's character her dad
like gave an out like oh well we based
the monsters on legends about monsters
in the woods so there was still like
there was still like some plausible
deniability oh well maybe there were
really monsters out there even though
most of them were fake
but
so i guess that's what she thought but i
think it would have been more impactful
if they had just switched the
that scene to like
late to earlier like before you knew
that the monsters were not real that's
all i'm saying yeah it doesn't matter i
don't it wouldn't have improved the
movie that much it was a good movie it's
but you know what i mean i don't think
it would have changed it that much maybe
i think that what happened with this
movie and i and i experienced this as
well because like i said i saw this in
the theater
um you know obviously m night
came out with the sixth sense which was
like a monster [ __ ] hit it made like
700 bajillion dollars
uh you know on a very very modest budget
and that's still a great movie that's
still you know i that still holds up and
then like he made um you know signs and
unbreakable which didn't make quite as
much money but we're still like pretty
critically you know an audience
successful with audiences there was a
whole unbreakable trilogy there yeah i
know but i'm talking about prior i'm
prior to this movie coming out
so i kind of feel like up until that
point you know even though he made the
sixth sense and that was amazing and
then the other movies people were like
well it's not quite as good as the sixth
sense but it's still pretty awesome
this movie seemed to be the turning
point where
m night started to become like on like a
downward slide you know what i'm saying
because i kind of feel like people saw
this the problem is and we've talked
about this before and i think we talked
about this when we were talking about
the sixth sense
is that
he came to be known as the twist guy
so now it's kind of like you can't even
and that's what i mean when i say i
think it was actually better for me to
watch the village a second time knowing
what the twist was so you could actually
appreciate the movie without sitting
there trying to figure out what the
twist is you know what i'm saying yeah
so i think that's better to like do and
that's why i liked watching the sixth
sense a second time too because knowing
what the twist is you can actually
appreciate it a lot more because you can
see how it was all constructed
you know and i think the same thing was
true here
um but the thing about it so this came
out another thing that's interesting too
and i saw another critic point this out
was that up to this point in his career
m night had always made movies that were
very much grounded in the real world but
then introduced a supernatural element
usually as the twist you know what i
mean like oh bruce willis was dead the
whole time or you know uh or uh whatever
bruce willis was a superhero or whatever
so he introduces supernatural elements
this one
inverted that to the sense where
they set it up like it was supernatural
like a monster movie
but then it was like scooby-doo ending
it was like they weren't real oh and
also
it's the modern day and it's not 1897.
it means there was like two twists so it
was kind of interesting how he tried to
invert it and i think at the time it
didn't really work and i think one of
the problems too and i think even m
knight brought this up
is that because prior to this he'd
always kind of done horror sci-fi type
movies
this was absolutely marketed as a horror
film
um it's not quite a horror and it's not
not really and i because i remember the
trailers being like oh man that looks
really cool because the whole setup was
like there was this creepy village and
it was like in the middle of nowhere and
there's all these monsters in the woods
and there was like in the trailers like
all the you know you get glimpses of the
thing with like the red
cloak on and like all the people with
yellow cloaks and i'm like man that
looks pretty cool and it looks pretty
creepy and like the first part of it is
creepy but you have to approach it
it's not a horror movie not really not
really it's honestly kind of like a love
story or kind of like a drama
but yeah it needed a bigger horror
element probably i mean the tone it
reminded me a lot of wicker man and
midsummer but without
the folk horror part
yeah more like folk religion
it felt like the weird thing is that
they weren't really religious no
well it's a religion it is but they
weren't really it's just it's like a
secular religion yeah their religion
wasn't to protect innocents and to keep
the [ __ ] cult together you
know some people have you know what i
mean some people say well if it doesn't
have this and it's not a religion
religions don't have to have gods in
them
religions don't have gods in them
and it's like that it's like a cult it's
like a cult
religion and it's almost kind of like
worshiping the past the 1800s yeah
that's exactly what it is it's almost
kind of like but that's another thing
too is that and something that you sort
of pointed out we were watching the
movie is that well you know there are
communities that do this like the amish
and stuff like the amish but they don't
raise their children to pretend like
it's 1897 and come up with all of these
they do kind of come up with oh you know
if you go to the city
they might come up with some kind of
[ __ ] where everything out there is
dangerous yeah you know you know they do
do that in a way though they are larping
that it's the 1800s that's true you
can't have anything that's high-tech you
got to go out there and build cows you
got to [ __ ] make cheese no technology
you can't have a car no they're not
saying cars don't exist they're just
that's that's that's the distinction
it's not part of their world they're not
a car yeah they're not lying to their
children and saying what's you know that
totally none of that even is out it's
basically what the amish are doing it's
just that they they just added a new
a new veil of
kind of religiosity over they're not
even going to have it at all like it's
just not out there you know that it is
the 1800s
it's just yeah that's just kind of what
they did and like i said and i and i've
kind of brought this up before but it's
like you know going back to 1897 is
absolutely not going to solve any of
your problems because holy [ __ ] and like
i said i kind of like that the first
shot of the film which is one of the
elders crying over the coffin of his
dead son who could have been saved if
they had medicine if they weren't so
[ __ ] dead set on going out to those
wicked towns and like getting some god
and honestly they it and that's another
thing that i only just that only just
occurred to me they didn't even have to
go to the towns she went to the ranger
station and they had medicine there yeah
so it's like they wouldn't even have to
go that far you could just go through
the woods so they don't have to even go
and associate
if their whole thing if they're if the
elders were so afraid of you know well
we can't go to the towns because we'll
get raped and murdered which is you know
unlikely but you wouldn't have to go
that far you just had to go to the
ranger station and get medicine yeah by
1890s the 1890s was not
a peaceful time
i mean yeah i mean i guess that was just
like an arbitrary yeah kind of thing
well and some people have pointed out
too and like i said you could find
logical inconsistencies all day long
it's like if you know if the kids that
grew up there didn't know any better why
would you have to talk like that right
but but the thing about it and i think
one of the main criticisms is that m
knight
does things for the sake of the audience
right that in in world in the movie
world the characters would not do right
another logical inconsistency i pointed
out i did not absolutely did not notice
this the first time well obviously i
didn't notice it the first time because
i didn't know what the twist was but now
i do so
okay so sigourney weaver
was one of the elders
absolutely she had the black box in her
house that had all the stuff and she
said that her husband because she was a
widow right her husband got robbed and
like mugged and killed and left in the
east river so she was one of the elders
so you would think i mean she's one of
the elders then she met them in the
grief group so she would know
about the fake monsters right
you would imagine yeah but there's one
scene between her and william hurt
where like after all the animals turned
up skinned
and she says you know and the red marks
are on the doors she says yeah those red
marks that's too high up for a coyote
why are those two saying that to each
other because presumably they both know
that the monsters are fake it's just um
it's just putting on a show for the kids
yeah but nobody else was there oh i
don't know it was the two of you yeah
that's what i mean so i think that's
what a lot of people um
kind of take issue with with m night's
movies is that he does things for the
benefit of the audience
that in the movie if if that movie was a
real world
that wouldn't happen like that
conversation wouldn't have occurred
understand you're being logical and
reasonable yeah yeah yeah no i'm just
saying because it's art yeah yeah well
no that's what i'm arguing i'm just
saying that if you come at it from that
point of view you can find all kind of
[ __ ] wrong with it but honestly
watching it
um you know even though
from a realistic logical point of view
it doesn't really make a lot of sense
but
as a sort of allegory about
innocence and about
trump like like trading in
it's kind of like a meditation on like
fear
and
sort of like what what are you willing
to trade away for quote-unquote security
even though you will never achieve it i
like the movie yes i do as well
my problem with it was is that it was a
good movie but it would have made a much
better
twilight zone episode yes many people
have made the twilight zone really it is
a very twilight zone yeah yeah because
it's it's contrived but like i said
shorter and smaller yeah if not when it
at this length it has to be filled out
with a lot more stuff in it
yeah it was getting kind of
the reveals were getting kind of slow
like it's going well okay what's okay
what's the next step now you know i mean
you might have
10 minutes of damn dialogue
happening and you know you're being
fooled to be to believe in a world that
isn't real i i'm already calling
[ __ ] on the on the 1890s thing and
it takes forever for the [ __ ] twist
to be revealed and you know it's there
yeah and like i said i think that's why
a lot of his movies suffer and i think
this was even though this one got mixed
reviews like it got good reviews at the
time but some people like were like i
said pointing out logical
inconsistencies
um and i think it suffered too because
people were expecting it to be a horror
film uh because that's how they marketed
it and it's not really a horror film
it's more like a like a creepy drama
love story type of thing with some kind
of creepy horror elements but not really
fake i give it a b minus
now you cut 20 minutes out of it maybe
30 minutes it'd probably go up to an a
like i said i mean there's a really lot
that i like about this movie i really
like um i really like bryce dallas
howard in it she's great uh joaquin
phoenix he's great and everything um so
all the acting is good the visuals are
beautiful the movie looks spectacular
and i really really like
all of the like the color coding like i
like all the red being like the danger
color which is funny because this came
out in 2004
so a lot of people kind of conflated it
with
uh you know the amber the yellow being
like the safe color and then the red
being the danger color like those you
know iraq war
color-coded
kind of things which
that you could see it like that because
like i said this is a very much
it's almost kind of like you could say
it's like an allegory for like security
theater
because because the the elders think
they're gonna like we're gonna get away
from the real world we're gonna move to
this like isolated little village where
nobody's gonna come in nobody's gonna go
out and we're keeping everybody in here
by saying there's some other there's
monsters like out in the woods so no one
can leave so it's kind of it's that kind
of thing they're trying to scare
everybody into like staying in there but
obviously and it works for most people
but joaquin phoenix's character uh you
know bryce dallas howard's character
whose name is ivy by the way
um
you know they even though they grew up
here
they
are not really afraid they're not i mean
they're afraid of what's in the wood but
they're not so afraid that they're not
curious and they want to like go out and
that's kind of like where the conflict
starts and ivy ends up being
like kind of like the bravest character
you know what i mean yeah although i
think it would have been better
i don't know like i said i think it
would have been better for them to
reveal that the monsters were fake
before
she went out in the woods because what
they did like he he told everything in
sort of like a linear timeline but then
he was like uh you know she's there and
her dad's gonna tell her that the
monsters are fake because she has to go
out in the woods and he doesn't want her
to be afraid which fair enough
but um
he doesn't tell her that it's the modern
world out there but i don't know if that
would make any sense to her though
because it would be like out of context
now earlier on in this review you said
that m knight [ __ ] went down on the
downward slope i might have to disagree
well no in like perce in perception
public perception that's what i meant
yeah because uh he he's ended up pr
pretty strong if he asked me with that
damn superhero trilogy with chad
although
yeah right well the thing about well i'm
talking about just in time like this
came out and this kind of like like i
said prior to this most of his movies
had made a lot of money this made a lot
of money yeah uh prior to this most of
it is a hot flavor of the day for a
while yeah and it's like and they and
they were critically well uh received
too this one kind of started getting
mixed and then the next one lady in the
water everybody [ __ ] on that i heard
that was i heard it was bad but i
haven't seen it i haven't seen it either
um but and i probably should before it's
but i just remember everybody [ __ ]
on it and saying this is the worst movie
ever um honestly i think the movie of
his that got the worst reviews was the
last airbender uh which i also haven't
seen but everybody just said that was a
total [ __ ] dumpster fire but like i
said i haven't seen it so i can't say
and then he made the happening
which
is like a lot of people like it because
it's unintentionally hilarious
um but i don't think that anybody like
seriously thinks it's a good movie but
then after that he seemed to start
coming back some like he made the visit
uh you know he made split which was
actually really really well received um
so that was almost kind of like his
comeback i think i feel like split was
maybe the comeback i can't remember if
the visit came out before or after i
heard that one was good too but like i
said after this one
um like i said i liked this movie but i
didn't like it enough to keep watching
his movies because all the ones that
were on the downward spiral like lady in
the water and stuff like that i just
didn't bother with them
but
revisiting this one like i said if you
haven't seen it in a long time but you
still know what the twist is because
like i said i feel like everybody knows
what twist is then maybe not as many as
know what the sixth sense twist is but
if you watch it
knowing what the twist is and not
expecting it to be a horror movie and
just kind of approaching it like a fairy
tale or an allegory
then i think it reads a lot better like
just try not to think too much about
like i said try not to think about too
much of the logic behind the situation
where
you know you know why do they still talk
like that if their kids don't have never
been to the outside world you know why
couldn't one of the elders just have
gone and got medicine why are they more
willing to let their children die
than just go to the damn ranger station
which is like right through the woods it
takes like a day and uh and bring it
back that's what i'm saying so so it
just wasn't enough
i kind of feel like i would have i think
it would have been a stronger story
overall if he could have found a better
reason
for the elders not leaving well i think
you just kind of show the ridiculousness
of it you know what i mean
yeah and maybe that denial of reality so
much that they'll they're willing to you
know [ __ ] kill their kids over it you
know what i mean which and yeah that's
kind of a futility i mean maybe that and
maybe that could actually work because
there are some people that are so up
their own buds with like their religious
kind of thing where it's like they will
absolutely not get like just regular ass
medicine for their kids because they're
so convinced that you know god's going
to save them or whatever so maybe you
could argue that they're coming at it
from that angle yeah you know what i
mean that's what i think it was which
yeah okay
i'll allow it
it's a decent movie i don't really have
much more to say about it but i will say
this
his best work
is um what is it shattered
no split spl no no no
unbreakable unbreakable split the
incoming glass those are the best wants
yeah a lot of people really like it does
his best ones i think i like the six i
think i like the sixth sense best but
but those ones are good too his take on
superheroes i thought was [ __ ]
fantastic well it's original i mean he's
got like some really good ideas and
honestly
his um
his his visual sense and his sense of
like symbolism and stuff like that is
really really good like the way the
shots are framed in this movie the
symbolism that he uses like um one one
shot that i or a couple shots that he
does in the village that i hadn't even
realized until i watched it again
but there's a couple shots where like uh
joaquin phoenix and uh bryce dallas
howard are just about to kiss it's like
their first kiss and it's a big love
story and everything like that and it
cuts away to like an empty rocking chair
and then later on after bryce dallas
howard finds him stabbed
it also cuts to an empty rocking chair
symbolism being you know uh eventually
one of them is gonna die like gonna get
old and die and one will have to live
without the other one and i was just
kind of like holy [ __ ] i never even like
caught that the first time like i said
it doesn't make any sense that there
would be like an empty rocking chair in
the middle of a field like that but it's
still but like i said he's a very
symbolic
filmmaker an allegorical filmmaker and
i kind of feel like looking at the movie
through that lens instead of trying to
be like well you know that would never
work in real life yeah you know i i'm
kind of willing to give him the benefit
on the down on this one because like i
said i haven't seen this since 2004
and
watching it again i was kind of like
that's actually a much better movie than
i remembered
and it's interesting that i read some
other pieces like in different mags like
a collider and some other places and it
seems like in the last few years
especially since old came out which was
his newest movie a lot of people have
kind of been reassessing the village
and they're kind of saying yeah it's
like we saw this at the time and it
pissed us off because we were expecting
a horror movie and we were like oh the
twist was dumb and all this other kind
of stuff but they're like re-watching it
they're like actually it's pretty
[ __ ] good you know what i mean so uh
so people are kind of like critically
reassessing it like you know like i said
it was kind of like the marketing too
that kind of got in trouble so it was
unbreakable
split and glass right yeah all right now
here's something else i want to bring
with you guys there's a possibility i
was analyzing i was over analyzing it
there's a possibility that the sixth
sense might also be in that same
universe because you know
being able to interact with the dead
that's a superpower too in a way that's
like something doctor strange or
memphisto or some [ __ ] like that you
know you that might
because you know super powers were also
kind of like abilities
so
for all we know
the kid from the sixth sense might be in
that universe huh
yeah it could be he does that a lot
because somebody pointed out to me like
in or pointed out like in one of their
reviews of the village
that uh the character at the end because
you know how m knight like shows up in a
lot of his own movies yeah um he shows
up in this but you only see in the
village but you can only see like the
back of his head
and his character's name like he's the
guy that kind of like runs the security
detail around the [ __ ] and he knows
about the people in there but he's not
supposed to tell anybody
uh his character's name is jay
and he plays a character named jay in
that trilogy
so we're wondering if that's like if
he's like the same repeating character
so like all his movies are
technically in the same universe yeah i
guess i could see that
because like i said this is you know
even though this seems like a period
piece it's totally not it's set around
the same time period and it's set in the
same area because
it's set in pennsylvania they do say
that it's pennsylvania because all his
shit's in philadelphia because that's
where he's from
but uh but yeah so but yeah i had that
pointed out to me too that it's like
that that character was the same it
might be the same universe
yeah well it totally could be yeah i
mean this one which
which that might mean that signs might
be in the same thing
let's just make all this the oh and this
is the verse
he extended the extended thing but yeah
so the village is on hulu right now um
if you haven't seen it then sorry we
just spoiled the pretty much the whole
movie for you but like i said i kind of
feel like it's just maybe not as
widespread as the sixth sense because i
feel like even everyone's grandma that
didn't even see the sixth sense knows
what the [ __ ] twist of that is um i
do kind of feel like most people know
what the twist is actually the village
has two twists one that the monsters
aren't real and two
that that's the modern day and not 1897
but
um but yeah if you haven't seen it a
long time
i think it's really interesting to watch
it
without like already knowing what the
twist is well it's outside the context
of the time yeah
you're not expecting a
horror movie because you haven't been
hit with the advertising campaign it's
just a it's just a movie yeah just watch
it honestly and the ki and i felt like i
watched a few other reviews from people
who saw it at the time like in the
theater like i did and they had the same
experience they said the trailers made
it look like a really scary monster
movie is essentially what they so that's
what everybody went in expecting yeah
and that's not really what it is
um but i think even m night like i said
at some conventions has said that i
really wish i could go back in time and
redo the marketing for that so
so it would more like accurately reflect
what kind of movie it is so people
weren't expecting because i kind of feel
like maybe
that was some of the reason that people
for advertising were like uh there's
like yeah it wasn't really a monster
movie it was more like a love story
false advertising hate yeah i think
that's what it was well you know you you
can't like give the whole movie away but
you have to manage people's expectations
too it's like people don't really like
people like being surprised but people
don't want to like go in expecting one
kind of movie and getting a totally
different kind of move you could you
could take star wars and if you
advertise that as a movie about catching
a big ass shark it's gonna flop
i would like to see somebody do that
that would be super funny in like the
first couple of minutes you're like what
the [ __ ] is the first couple of minutes
they're like on the ocean going where's
that shark at and then like it goes into
space inexplicably yeah that would be
super funny but yeah marketing it's
important kids but yeah so uh like i
said if you haven't seen it a long time
go check it out again and let me know
what you thought of it do you still love
it do you still hate it uh what how do
you feel about the twist let us know in
the comments and we will see you on the
next one
bye
you